and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 32 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord who I
consider Xbox royalty whom I've had the
pleasure of meeting at the flesh in my
very first III in 2015 at the time this
Lord held on to one of the greatest
technological secrets in Xbox gaming
history while smoothly speaking to me
prior to the Microsoft press conference
no snitching this fight is for
professional stature in the community
this law is extremely down-to-earth
personable and it is always a pleasure
bumping into him and each and every
Microsoft event to discuss what we all
know and love these great games
introducing the principal program
manager lead and the pride of the Xbox
platform team the Lord directly
responsible for ushering an Xbox 360
backward compatibility to the Xbox one
as well as the US Marine slash Detective
the Xbox realm the Great War himself
MAME
Lord bill still well how are we doing
sir hey guys if I can live up to that is
your Lord in your room when we have to
show you the proper respect when you got
the round table awesome thanks for
having coming through and of course we
have the usual suspects at the round
table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother
and the house of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how are we doing sir pretty
good just actually kind of have like
that vibe that I won't play more destiny
to unfortunately you got to do the show
carefully best and of course our most
technical gaming part the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience
you gotta be always offline profile
Illuminati now one day doesn't change
the name man it could be better
whole situation in Puerto Rico yeah the
contact family since Wednesday so it's
suffering and even more so for my wife
cuz I mean her entire family's over
there so you know just hoping for the
best I'm waiting to hear some word
I hate thoughts and prayers to the
family that's gotta be rough out there
absolutely and of course the excess
gamer oh the lord of combat sports who
was a man of his convictions and demands
nothing less than the premium experience
Oh beloved Lord King how are we doing
sir
we're doing fantastic my thoughts and
prayers go out to everyone in Puerto
Rico you know my grandmother side is
from Puerto Rico and we heard from a
couple of family members because they
went to an adjacent town and was able to
get word out that you know everybody's
okay but switching gears let's get into
what I do boxing last night Jose Linares
versus County it was a fantastic fight
totally rolling my eyes right now
it was fantastic last night also you had
the recap of Canelo vs triple G so you
can actually see a robbery in progress
[Laughter]
and I don't normally do this but shout
out to Carmelo forgetting out thank you
brother oh we talked about yes yes
Carmelo Anthony has found his way to OKC
thank the heavens for getting him there
I tell it such as that should not be
wasted in an organization that is a
cesspool alright
oh my god bill girl of course let's not
kid give it a toss what's update lord
cogito here spreading that gaming
realness on the ILP not telling you what
you want to hear or what you need to
hear so before we get into what the
Lords of plain
I want to start off with a lord builds
his video game system history I know we
share that incredible 3do experience but
would start from the beginning with him
with that I also want to talk about his
own asking about his career journey at
Microsoft for over 17 plus years and of
course his undeniable passion for the
sport of hockey and those NHL games so
let's get from the beginning as far as
your video game history your first
couple of systems that kind of stuff
what Bill alright let's start so when
you say go back to the beginning I'm old
so we really get to go back to the
beginning
let's do it she talked the very first so
I've always had a video game system I
got into computers when I was a kid we
had a Commodore vic-20 we had a Texas
and gentleman at a Radio Shack trs-80
but the very first game I actually
played was a buddy of mine when I was
when I was still in I think junior high
got a sleepover at his house his dad was
a scientist that one of the nuclear labs
outside of Chicago and they had an
actual modem the old 300 baud suction
cup while indicative modem and and he
had mainframe access at his house with a
terminal so I went over to Eric's house
we were playing he said I won't show his
cool game he puts the modem any dials in
the mainframe he's and he launches what
effectively was adventure or Zork look
at this it didn't even have a monitor on
it it had a dot matrix printer so you
tricks into banner and then you print
out so you roll it up and you'd read
what happened next
and then you get soared and you hit
enter and then you'd read what happened
next we we played through the entire
game I have no idea what this cost to
lab man and somewhere I still have this
thick stack of dot matrix printer paper
with the holes on the side the holes of
the side of the whole thing just stacked
up
is classic backslash you officially win
on the oldest game play we had on the
show just all this game like we go back
and you know we we say stuff like a
Commodore or we say stuff like Amiga
but bro thanks a bit so then where did
the progression go from then after that
well well you know just like any kid
growing up in that era you know there
was always the family gaming system
back then you had to slide the little
thing on the back from TV to computer
when the RF the RF a car adapter and
then I will I will admit I always I feel
shame over this I was never a big
Nintendo guy the one that hooked me the
most was the Genesis my man pale stable
look give it up for you world my heart
what you said Mario's great leagues
great they're great they're great
franchises and they're a ton of fun but
we had by this by the time I got a
little bit older in the Marine Corps we
had a Genesis in our squad bay and like
you'd come back and and MBA and AHL were
never out of that thing it didn't matter
you could come back off of patrol and
someone would be up and some of me get
ready to go to bed and you just sit down
take their seat and everybody played you
know their City yes and and I just
played that console so much and because
it's that way you know and this is I
think one of the great things about
gaming is that it you just bond with
your with your friends over it and
that's trash talking and everything that
went on and we played that thing just
and you card it around with you it's
real ative ly indestructible compared to
someone today the slap cartridges in
just keep playing wherever you went and
that was that was my real system I got
out of the Marine Corps and suddenly
have money and so of course what do I do
I go what's the best game system you
could buy and that's when I bought the
3do
Oh about that oh I still love that
system and I love the idea of it I have
the opportunity to meet trip Hawkins
right around it right after that you
know you just you build a reference
architecture and I mean if you think
about how just computer systems work
somebody builds a set of component
architecture someone builds an operating
system and then everybody gets the party
on it and I know that that the the
markets for gaming is shifted and even
within PC gaming you have the Nvidia
ante like if you have different camps a
capability but the idea of here's a
reference architecture for a media
system everybody can build it everybody
can build games for it yes making build
other stuff for it like I do think he
was one of the first to really publicly
talk about and look I know I didn't get
traction in 2013 either but the idea of
I have a single box it does everything
for me that is correct you're right it
was it was actually called 3do what is
it the interactive multiplayer something
to that effect so they would they really
trying to take over live woman so
interactive multiplayer and the idea was
it was at the time CD based yes system
but it could do anything
entertainmentwise right because that was
also when they started dabbling in the
full-motion video games what was the
what was the sewer one oh yeah was it a
solution yeah and a couple of those that
were just and they were pretty bad
actually but that was a cool but it was
just I mean and then Sony came out with
the PlayStation and just so undercut
them price-wise and produce great
content at a such a lower price point it
just it kind of doomed them yeah so now
what games did you rock out for I don't
want the radio if you remember
so obviously Road Rash roam fresh the
best Road ranch ever was even even the
soundtrack to that game like it just
fit everything perfectly you know the
time it's Soundgarden doing the I mean
it was awesome
yes it was Road Rash it was need for
speed um actually like Jurassic Park
interactive I think was that one mad was
the first one where you saw like what
looked like real players that it just
the pixel it was it was it the first
blood bill wasn't the first 3d mad into
at the time like it I mean I know I
remember i remember playing Madden it
just my jaw hit the floor like oh my so
metric I believe it was still isometric
I was looking that was the one where you
used to play Lord High and you had that
over the middle play that was kind of
like sauce up to my wire receiver baby
Paul I killed before like we found like
exploits and certain play goals always
that one play that you could all you
just call over over and over again what
about ganks oh the dark way of the
warrior way to know where to this day
wasn't crash and burn the pack into yes
dogs earlier titles to and then there
was another game that they had Space
Hulk
yeah what's funny is I think it was
based on the Warhammer 40k series of
games I have never played a Warhammer
game in my life but but that game hooked
me for some reason and I love that I
still have appreciate the story tickled
I fact that element of hammer yeah now
you beat mid nineties yeah absolutely
and one other one I remember um I don't
know if you guys remember it was a it
was I believe was Crystal Dynamics his
early entries it was a game called total
eclipse it was like a 3d spaceship kind
of a game it looked beautiful for its
time really good scaling I don't know if
you remembered Lord King it was kind of
like a three spaceship kind of swing man
yeah oh they had when it came out it was
one of the last couple of games and
shout out to three deal for being the
first system that you had to get a
finance on going in a store and I picked
it up and I did not like the fact that
they came out with the cheap of five
hundred dollar model what was a Goldberg
after that that 3d override levels are
their PlayStation we know comes out we
know Flay station you know the like you
said the lower pricepoint
tremendous backing you know so did you
jump on board then or what was your next
was far as your progression
yeah so I play station when it first
came out I had that for a while and then
ice about right around the time and then
I started Microsoft in 2000 so right
before we released the initial Xbox and
I've had both of those consoles and
through every one of their iterations
mmm mostly because I had a PSP at one
point like I'll try all out dissing it I
love the idea the PSP but you know
having one thumb stick didn't make a lot
of sense yeah kind of doomed it yeah and
so and since then I've always I've
always had a PlayStation and Xbox and
every time a new iteration comes out
I'll grab them nice nice cool about this
which bill so I have not been able to
get my own switch I was going to get
water
try to get one they're sold out here
part of the problem of a being where
Xbox is and then Nintendo's like a block
away yeah nothing lasts in any of our
stores but I love the concept you know I
think that I mentioned that I had
appreciated the concept when 3d ok ma I
think at some point and maybe I'm
foolish because it's been 20 years the
industry has to move to the point where
Portability and sort of access to your
content just always there yeah and I'm
not I'm not
that's not PR speak for me tied back to
the competitor but I mean like
realistically gamers just want to game
and as a matter if I'm on a bus or a
plane or at home I want to have I want
entertainment and and that's where I
think the switch has done some great
work in short of proving that there's a
market it doesn't have to be I mean look
the Xbox one X is amazing gears in 4k
with Atmos is unbelievable when I
actually saw for the first time but it
doesn't always have to be that amazing
for you to enjoy it I think switches
yeah and it's also helping to sort of
define the industry struggles with the
notion of the social engagement of
gaming and switch is sort of showing a
different dynamic it's not about clips
and sharing a broadcast that all exists
it's all popular but here's a different
dynamic which is just you can pick it up
and play it anywhere you want and you
can also just join people while you're
on the road great point yeah I mean I
think I think you nailed it with that I
think the portability like you said and
just being able to just pick up on the
go and and like you say we all know it's
not the most powerful system you know
but they are proving you know the
skeptics wrong as far as that different
they're showing that there is a market
for it is it just that different base
that is clamoring for games and not
necessarily the most powerful thing so
it's interesting to see you see their
development right now that's pretty cool
so telling you that you can get that
switch right now on Amazon so long I'm
actually at the point now where I'm
gonna wait for holiday bundles guys and
then not get those - do me a favor make
sure I pick up that bundle in November
and I help me win a bet on the Isle of
we call the second we call it meant to
be so half of the lords are predicting
who we think will win November MPD and
the other half so Microsoft intended in
other words he's saying half the Lords
are gonna be wrong which is inside and
the other half is gonna be right which
is our side though that could be fun
it's gonna be fun so that we've got that
that career as far as the video game
history let's start off Federer at
Microsoft and and how did you get
started you know in the in your whole
journey did I sort of ended up here by
accident actually
it's a it's an interesting story because
every was like well how did you get into
the industry and I totally fell into it
by mistake
mm-hmm when I was in college I tried to
go to I try to listen rapport nice boy
was still too young my dad says no he go
with college so while I was in college
and I was now old enough I dropped out
of school and enlisted in the Marine
Corps again and all I wanted to do is
Drive things and there's olive
everyone's just drive tanks and then
maybe be a police officer when I got
through when I retired from the Marine
Corps so I showed up once the recruiter
said hi can I get into tanks he said yet
no problem so I took the initial test
for what I was qualified you have to hit
min minimum levels and you're what they
call the Armed Forces vocational
aptitude battery correct and he came
back he said hey you still do tanks but
you did really really well and we liked
you to do military intelligence instead
mmm well I want to do tanks but and so
he kept negotiating with me and
eventually he got me to commit to that
which was actually I love that job and
one of the things about it was I did
signals intelligence in cryptography so
I spent a lot of time working on
computers and I spent a lot of time
working with technology so when I got
out of the Marine Corps I had a security
clearance I had all this background so I
was able to do a lot of consulting and
make good money doing it and I had a
good time at it with always the belief
that okay well now I'm out I'll go at
least get become police officer next
year right and then everybody apply and
you go well but the money is really good
we don't do one more year
and that went on for some time and up
until the point where we moved out to
Seattle from Chicago my wife and I did
and I got a call from recruiters said
hey we got you sell your background we'd
like to hire you for Microsoft I said
great so I applied and in fact I was
tell people this I got I applied for two
jobs the first job I interviewed for
they turned me down and it was one for
support and they said I wasn't qualified
but it's like a week later the other
team call me back and so I started
working in Microsoft in their
communication sector which is a
consulting practice that they had built
to help telecom with some of our
infrastructure systems and so the very
first project ended for Microsoft was I
was working with kpn the Dutch telephone
company in the Netherlands converting
their mail system over to a hosted
exchange we now hosted exchange at the
time we didn't so it was try to convert
an enterprise messaging system into a
into an ISP based fun-loving this is all
tech jargon I'm loving this could
continue so then I did that I was in
that group for a while mostly around
mobile and telecom infrastructure and
then I left because of course since I
had a security background the first
thing Microsoft did was put me on
messaging products I probably got back
into security after those and after that
first year and a half I eventually
started working with Windows on some of
their security work around Windows XP
sp2 and IE and at the time Microsoft was
building out a Security Response Team I
dressed a bunch of threats you know this
is when the internet was starting to
just kind of blow up and yeah they take
care of vulnerable --'tis and those
threats network yeah things like Code
Red and nimda that just took systems
down and so we started working with ISPs
on how do you how do you cut this off at
the core routers and things like that so
I did that for a few years then I went
back to mobile did some entertainment
infrastructure services in Mobile for a
number of years and then left again went
to Bing mobile ads saw apologized so
yeah banner ads my fault
a little bit low then we went and so
then I actually went back and this time
by now Windows Mobile had been converted
to Windows Phone I went back there and
worked on that system for a while and
through all of this I done a number of
Xbox projects I was involved in the
initial infrastructure rollouts with
telecom for Xbox Live and 2000 and I
still have my NFL fever
xbox live demo this Wow and it fell out
and then I did some when I was the
second time I was back in Mobile we did
some infrastructure work because
xbox live video was becoming a thing and
I got an opportunity to go to the Xbox
team and went to store so for I went
join the Xbox team in 2012 working on
what was at the time just the Xbox tour
of the single store just for the
consumer for the console business Dennis
correct after the launch of the Xbox one
that team got reorg into the overall
store so now we have a consolidated
store for Microsoft and then I moved
over to the Xbox platform team massive
launch for Xbox one in China so we did
Wow
second rollout for China first console
ever released into that market that is
correct yeah Wow they've been illegal
there for over a decade through the free
trade agreements that they've got our
free trade zones they've set up in
Shanghai and somewhere else we're now
able to work with the government and
ship an Xbox there mm-hmm
Alex are the chances bill get them to
put a car in the in the store this is
not a long after that I came back over
after we launched it in everything
launched the console in China
my boss Kevin gamble who some you saw
may be selling the digital found your
article yeah
runs all a platform said hey I want
someone to run the 360 platform and go
work with this other team when I said
sure I'll run the 360 platform I'm fine
with that
and so I picked that up well it turned
out that was also a team that was doing
the the 360 back compact program I
started I picked I'm married up with
Kevin LaChapelle who the and my
engineering manager
this on this team and the rest is sort
of history that is a beautiful last name
dice so we get to that 360 Wow yeah he's
I I've been I've been here long time
there's been like two or three times
where everything just coalesce is right
and you end up on a team of it's what I
love about this company
there are you you start to realize just
how brilliant some of the people are
that you get to work with yeah this is
and I say this even though they're not
none of them are near me so I can say it
and still be sincere like I love these
guys they are so smart and they're so
submitted and what I love about them the
most is they're gamers first a lot of
our engineers have their in the credits
of other games they've been involved in
the industry for a long time and there's
just sort of this commitment to even to
themselves that this is just what people
want and so we're gonna figure out a way
to do it thanks just some brilliant
brilliant guys and I love working with
facts now I want to backtrack you for a
second when we talked about the you know
getting over to 3/16 becoming on a
platform team now that transition the
Xbox one I mean you talked I'll never
forget it it was you know Xbox it was e3
2015 and you know Phil comes out the
guys come out you come out you know and
just make them England up with the fans
but what you guys don't get enough
credit for I mean you guys really are
gamers first you always talk to the
community you always person what we
really respect and appreciate you guys
it was funny because like I remember is
yesterday we're talking about it and
shots were made a lord rule we try to
make a little prediction before the show
what do you think Xbox one's gonna show
and yadda yadda yadda and then you just
had a smirk on your face the whole time
I just remember it like yesterday
if the after the show we talked in like
you guys dropped that bombshell of Xbox
360 compatibility and I'm just like bill
how did you do it remember I was just
like i understanding prior to that like
Lord King Lord sovereign I like we come
from that era where in order to have
backward compatibility you know a piece
of the core architecture from the old
platform had to be included in the new
platform right yeah
so we're sitting and we like well they
don't have 8360 components it's
completely different architecture like
how to do it and you just smell you like
a relation baby and I'm like wow so just
bring me back to that whole announcement
that whole process and getting that
bingo about compatibility you know
that's got to be one of the highlights
for me just facts here because it's
always tough when you build stuff
because you're never quite sure how it's
gonna be received and I mentioned I was
in Windows Mobile Windows Phone for a
lot of my career here you know it's hard
to see something that you just invest in
and people just kind of in or worse
they're at they're antagonistic towards
I don't mean in a poor me way like it's
just part of the job but yeah it was the
here's the best part of that was that it
wasn't just the way it was received a
they didn't leak the best part about it
was the think of things like three times
but everybody kept saying now it's not
possible so I watched that on Xbox Live
and we were sitting there when it came
up like that's the that is by far the
least thing I ever expected like usually
I can I'm pretty good besides last ether
yet everything announced I just
completely went over my head I was like
I did not expect half of this but like
particularly that that are that
announcement for that for backwards
compatibility it was like yep they you
know they they completely got me this
year I'm dead it was that was the great
part but the better part was that night
when we were at the at the mall when you
guys all wanted to get tickets Major
Nelson Larry would just introduced me as
the 360 program manager or something
along those lines he's like oh you know
my favorite game on the 360 was this or
my favorite game on the 360 was this and
it was so rewarding to know like we were
gonna show Mass Effect at the time we
knew Red Dead was on the horizon and we
just had to work through some of the
other sides of it was gonna come out
like it was great to hear people talk
about how much they loved these series
and missed them you know when they were
coming and I think that's really where I
think that's where you started to
appreciate as a someone who builds
things the impact it has on
yes I have become super convicted that
one of the challenges this industry has
that we need to work through is that
games are very transitory in terms of
their popularity because people think of
them in this is the next release and
then this is the next release and then
this is the next release and now it's a
remaster and now it's you know it's an
add-on free a prelude PAC or whatever
but they're no different and I've said
this to other people before there's no
there no difference between them as an
art form as books or movies or music and
the reality is there's new music that
comes out that I love and I still go
back and I listen to classic music there
are movies that are Star Wars right like
who would ever say well don't watch the
original Star Wars cuz now rogue ones
out like they're all good Knightley's
and people forget that games yeah the
graphics have changed but if they're
good games they're still good games
exactly I played through the Mass Effect
series again after we did all three of
them nice I forgot how much I loved that
series like Andromeda comes out and and
I hadn't played it in forever and so I'm
gonna go back to play the other ones
before I start and just had a blast the
other part to this is that there's an
entire generation again gamers that have
never played these games before yes red
Dead's an example of that right like I
love that game but it's older and so my
son he's never even heard of that game
before he's younger right so he's never
know it exists unless I expose them to
it Mass Effect's the same way or the
bioshock's they're good stories they're
good there and isn't there a lot of fun
just like and this isn't a backward
compatibility thing but for one when MCC
came out actually she came out oh yeah
first thing I do is I sat down my son
and we played multiplayer co-op all the
way through the campaign split-screen
nice like he loved that's that that was
and it's not just because it was the
game it was me and my son together like
just those things never change and
people forget that that history is a
rich history that we need to keep going
absolutely I mean you made some great
points day like you said because there's
such is there's a generation that just
never even experienced these great games
we're talking about sort of it's able to
bring that back and I know there was
some controversy recently in reference
to you know how many people are playing
it and I'm glad you guys and shout out
to you and Michael Barr and you guys got
of it and numbers showed otherwise that
people are playing these games and you
know I believe when what is it black ops
2 was announced black up to is the only
game I've ever seen to be out for a last
gen in in chart when I got a Gamestop
and I pick up like you know I pick up
multiple copies of you know and
different on different platforms I'm
like man it's got an oil question I have
for you reference to the to the program
was that I know it's gotta be telling me
on your Twitter mentions with you know
people are like hey what's up with Title
X why is it you know such as such covet
and you know in the past you've actually
commented on like you know a lot of this
actually comes down to the publisher and
the timing of when they want to announce
something and you know they may have a
schedule so could you make it clear to
people that sometimes it's really not
always all Microsoft as to why said
title hasn't been released on backward
compatibility yeah you know it's look
the technology we I think it stated this
way we've proven that we can make the
tech work yes still over 400 games
clearly works there been enough number
reviews on performance we weren't as
great in the beginning but we've since
fixed that you know this is a
partnership industry where artists and
content creators have a have a belief
and a story for how to manage their own
brands and all we want to do is be in a
tailor for them you know you're I get
all the time what about this game what
about this game what about this game
sometimes it gets to be a little a
little much black ops 2 noise got high
but at the same time I will state this I
have never blocked anybody I get some
nasty ones oh my god but but I don't
ever block anybody because here's the
thing
we have to keep reminding ourselves that
for one person this one game that no one
else cares about was something special
to that Pro tremendous
and something will change because that's
just the nature of the industry people
different different rights people the
rights expired mmm it's so who knows but
you don't ever want to dissuade someone
from having the love that they have for
something grand it's great to see
somebody tweeted me I think yesterday
about like hey probably now on these
four games they put Deadly Premonition
in and I'm not all the Microsoft that's
a good game
the game was big that game was a blast
it was awful but it was also it was it's
nice to reminisce even if we don't ever
bring it to the program professionally
like personally I just enjoy reminding
myself oh I forgot about that game I
forgot about this game absolutely I'll
shout out the Lord Edgar ran into chat
he said let let bill know without
backward compatibility he wouldn't be
able to play Mass Effect series for the
first time this year so awesome you guys
made a lot if you go back because these
games like with now that you know
they're done you're like oh my god be so
cool to see it for the first time
absolutely and I know Microsoft is very
appreciative to you because without you
guys and your hard work we wouldn't have
game pass mini mass is comprised of at
least 75% of 360 games that's we work
with those guys all the time it's a good
it's a good business group you know it's
it's it's weird being in the industry
and also being a fan and I appreciate
that the the sentiment because people
don't realize like we are we may not get
it right but it's never it's funniest
people subscribe malicious intent to so
many things which I just don't
understand kind of sarcastic by nature
so there's times where I maybe make
comments that I shouldn't have like I'm
a jerk it's funny yeah oh two questions
actually looks like to chat yeah chat
heating up one you with the backward
Cabana
yeah pretty much they are shout Laura
Alex he's saying that uh could you
comment on a slow release of the
backward compatibility games or they're
just not enough games left to put on
backward compatibility or you guys
focusing more on the OG xbox back
compatibility since Phil announced it I
guess what was it last III so we all get
on other things
and I would also say that if you
actually go back and look at our release
schedules for last couple of years
things have been flow there's never been
a consistent run rate we'll have big
surges and then we'll have things go qui
and it's just depends it's it's it is a
seasonal business and there's a lot
going on right now so catching programs
still going strong I'm still gainfully
employed
believe that it's going to be pending
anytime soon nice well I want to give
you a shout out for bringing back one of
my favorite titles of all time which was
the classic arcade shinobi actually the
lords Noah actually bought the artist
right in my house that was one of my
dream games always wanted as a kid and
when you guys brought that back I was so
happy when we tweeted like getting a
thousand times that the original art you
know he was out of that and I guess my
only personal request is there was a
there was a silly Luo Voltron xbox
arcade live game that I miss about the
rights is through there but it is anyway
you could make that happen if I could
find a track forward on any game I
always tried I always try to get no you
missed we ever talks about games but
they always forget like a large part of
my childhood was playing it at the
arcade yes yes get on your bike take
your quarters ride to the arcade even
close up on the machine wait for your
turn yep and like that that was an
entire generation of gamers then those
things don't even exist a point right
now you get him all in bed for 30 bucks
yeah it's sad it was a whole culture
behind a tool like that it's not about
just playing it in your house it was the
whole atmosphere of waiting your turn at
a machine you put your quarter up there
at the top these kids will never know
like it was when we went to that story -
towards me isn't it
Buck's won't ever understand when we
went to 42nd Street that was great
adventures for us you know we've got $10
we got our quarters we went to the guy
in the booth and he like was like the
overlord looking at everyone and he's
like the king of the quarters and you
know we get those quarters in oh man
like sitting this inside of machine I
remember when Daytona was released not
my dollar and I put it inside my sat
inside and the chair was moving the
rumble and I lost my mind oh they won't
get these feelings they would also just
like the the the sense of community you
got and also the trash talking cuz I'm
sorry he's just a fighter you put your
core-drobe
before you smack you down and then you
get to the other line so many good
points from a competitive standpoint and
then they also think what Bill is people
forget like the arcade at that time that
was like the the debut of new tech you
you got to see how things advanced by
when a new arcade cabinet a new machine
came out you know and I remember saying
you like the Mortal Kombat's and things
like that that blew your mind at the
time and just how graphics just kept on
going to virtual fighters and so on and
so forth when you're just seeing you
know the Tekken's you just seen the
advancements whenever a new release
would come out and that would kind of be
you know the the set piece and then the
console was actually behind you know
yeah well that was remember Albert
Panello just tweeted out about one of
his favorite games was that Star Wars
vector one where oh and I actually I
actually had a Vectrex said you sat down
like all of a sudden it was like oh my
gosh just looks so real because they had
lines instead of graphics which were
really blocking the time so it was clean
did you miss out on calico Coleco was
not in your brain I had so I had lotsa
so I had an Atari 20s my my my friends
had the Intellivision and then my cousin
got colecovision and
Mekong and I was so jealous I'm making
that for Christmas and never got it one
last question of reference to the
genesis Eric cuz I know you're a big
sports guy you have we have to admit
like that error had some of the best
sports games Oh without a doubt without
a doubt be to be honest and when we
gonna go into the NHL history soon
that's what got me he is actually those
EA hockey games those you know Lakers
versus Celtics the sports games and the
the the a day was so good man like and I
believe was the one that had like Pliner
debuted I've got my angel 94 94 babe
[Laughter]
just progressed in it what a series
around the time - were mad like it was
still John Madden football and they had
the one break your leg in the ambulance
for drive Ave we could talk classic game
is about yeah let's not team but you're
undeniable passion for hockey we know
you always rep the sport you know we
know you know you play the games and
tell tell us about that and in that
whole process yeah so I grew up in
Chicago and hockey was always I got to I
got two brothers we're all Bears fans
which is roughly my one brother was
really into the White Sox
my other brother is really into
basketball and the Bulls and I was just
I was a Blackhawks guy um and then I
played his little kid not much but I
played growing up I played all the way
through teenagers like Club hockey
nothing significant and then but I've
always been a fan of sport so when my
son expressed an interest in playing the
game just sort of out of the blue and
maybe maybe because we're watching it
all the time ladies about 6 we took him
to flurries 5 we took him to hockey 1
and he started playing and I first
season when he was a might I was has to
be assistant coach I said to the other I
said to the head coach said you know I
haven't played it forever
and I love this game and I love watching
it and being a part of it and he said I
just I forgot how to play it he's like
just go to this one training camp
they have in the area so I went there
and like that for the first game I'm
like I forgot how much I loved this and
I had an old set of gold year so I
brought it out and his old gears but I
brought it out to the second practice
and like oh you played goalie you said
yeah a long time ago great witty goalies
and so I started I spent the rest of the
camp playing as a goalie and then got
drafted by this adult league team won
and so Wow and just kept play and now so
then I started playing like two teams
and then three teams and then the
following year they said I'm or two
years later my some about he moved up
from mites to squirts they said hey you
shouldn't be in a coach again I said
yeah sure there's you know assistant
coach you're opening the door you're
running drills that kind stuff the next
thing I know my name was on that one of
the teams Wow be the head coach and I
will say that what's reinforce the in HL
game I love the International game but
watching kids play it mmm
sort of flips the perspective a little
bit and you start to see the game just
from the pure passion of it yes and I'm
now I'm gonna coach I'm a coach again
for my son's team this year actually
coached two teams because he's on a
development team as well coach both of
those and it's just it's an honor to be
out there and joy to be out there and
see kids compete just cuz they love it
and and the other thing I love and this
is new for cuz when we grew up it was
different riders like I watched these
kids they don't watch the NHL the same
way I do we're all sit down I'll watch
the head start to finish
they'll watch clips on YouTube they'll
watch highlights you know why and it's
all via YouTube and what's amazing is
you know I had a kid last year whose
favorite player was Ovechkin and he
loves the capital and capitals it and
watch OB do things and then he go on the
ice and just try to do him with Joe
appreciation the fact that he couldn't
and it turns out he could not quite to
the level but and that's really where
that kind of read grounded me and how
much I just love this game mmm
so yes
coach couple teams I play I only play
one game or walk with one team during
the kids season just as a time and then
I pick up drop-ins like finite shape
like that one time permits but yeah I'm
on the ice this time of year I'm on the
ice five six days a week
oh wow so that's the that's the legend
of the great wall and I saw the great
wall strike
listen let me tell you something that's
telling you all you guys out there don't
give up all your dreams he had his dusty
equipment inside I'm gonna go out here
let's see whatever happens I love for
the game and look where he's at so trust
me when I'm telling you is that's
fantastic that's so being a Guardians
completely in the space when they talked
about doing the Mars mission
I applied immediately and I thought
variation Oh laughter my whole family I
thought I was joking and then I got like
a mail back for asking for more data and
I'll never forget because she's like oh
your mind we're not taking this family
to Mars because but then my daughter
threw a temper too I'm trying to tell
her like we can name the places after us
hey Bill how does it feel to have one
probably the only arguments that's been
in history about is that you can't y'all
family tomorrow real quick I was very
curious about like I said your energy
ministry and stuff like that because um
for me it's funny because you know I was
never you know where we're from you know
any child's really not prominent as far
as promoting the community and stuff
like that but I remember like playing
like the NHL games with Loredana stuff
like that cannon learn about the sport
and then my first I'll be honest like
you say like when you watch people play
and you see the passion that to me going
to a game is
than watching the game not just my
opinion and um I never forget it was
like was it 93 94 and um I was like
Rangers penguins and I didn't know any
of the players I didn't know anything
all I knew was who was that number 66
cuz this guy scored every goal possible
and I was like that's my man and it
comes to find out it was Mary o Lemieux
and he had like a 5 goal game
every possible goal scored and I'm like
I'm a penguin fits acquit NHL game I
would just buy it just to hike and play
with Lemieux and but they had yogur back
there you got a school me a little bit
like rape bork or something like that
yeah that was my team you know that
marriage for people who are who didn't
grow up in the in the hockey culture
that marriage between gaming and that it
really helped a lot of people kind of
get into it because those games are also
so good you know that kind of thing so I
always felt that was that was
interesting as far as sports I'll say a
few things about it the hard part about
hockey over any other sport is everybody
knows how to run everybody was going to
jump everybody knows how to do that and
then and then they have to learn a sport
around it
hockey actually have to learn how to
skate first and that's always
intimidating to people I will say this
I've had some co-workers who have never
skated never played hockey and I'll put
them through a kit there's a couple
adult camps out here that are like learn
to play camps and within one year
they're usually playing on a team and
some of them end up feeling pretty good
at all because it is it is a commitment
and it's but it is learning to run all
over again in a new way it is I remember
I used to do a little bit of it I mean I
didn't go through some like camp or
anything I think I'd die if I went
through something like that but like I
have a hard time roller skate much less
be you know like that that's then like I
have a hard time walking much less like
but I think that's part of it is is
there's a there's a intimidation factor
to start the sport especially as they
get older because a lot of these kids
like my son I've started with their 4 or
5 or 6
and so it's hard to jump in but then
once you do it or as you said once you
go see it live my question he's from LA
he's live here now but never played the
sport can't get him to go out on the ice
but we went up to Vancouver to see the
Blackhawks play the Canucks and we got
it on the glass and he was he was
stunned like his jaw hit the floor how
some guys are yeah how at let ik they
actually are
yeah and it's it and you know what I
actually think football I think is a
sport that was made for TV best of all
is another one when you see it live it
fundamentally changes the perspective
because you don't realize especially if
you're close to the court you know Rose
how big these guys are oh yeah you look
at like I remember watching the Bulls
and I'm like Steve Kerr he's a little
guy on the team and you actually see see
them person you like house gigantic it's
a good foot yeah you right it's all
they're definitely ones that are better
in person
I think basketball has that same thing
you know I might glance at basketball
right now and then they all look around
my height but if you ever meet any of
these people in person they they
towering over everyone looks at you like
King you're so huge like it's all
perspective like you said you know you
go ahead and go to the point you see
these things and you see how big these
guys are you a lot of perspective that
picture of I think it's Shaq and
Berkeley standing with the rock yes yes
oh they're beast beast cool so we got
the journey that's real cool and hot
love you got that in so we're gonna get
the show rolling we got up we want to
get into what the lords are playing so
um let's start off actually start for
Bill what what have you recently be
playing like as far as game wise what's
in here what's an assistant right now so
I play I still play overwatch pretty
regularly play just about every week I
just finished
what about Edith Finch mm which is a
really short sort of walking soon game
it's fantastic that snores is sovereign
notes off it's fantastic walking
simulator and I don't use that as a
negative term it's a fantastic game no
the reason why I said that bill because
um Lord sovereign is a proponent for
this game and I thought he would be
raising here that you are playing if you
haven't played it it's it's an amazing
story you know yeah it's it's very weird
and like each set piece is just very
cool and again like it's just one of
those things it takes what you know
whatever whatever people deem the
walking simulator to be it kind of
changes up the formula a little bit even
more so as something like in Tacoma even
going home yeah best of I would say go
play gone home also go play those games
you know you have to like there's a
simple mechanic to the game it's not
tough to play at all and yet that now
henshin it builds just through that I
was I was sort of stunned to step back
for a second and realize I was on edge
playing that game I think the only game
I've ever had that kind of on edge like
terrifying chill down my back was Friday
the 13th when Jason's like right going
by me so cool so yeah eat a fin in there
and anything anything else but I was
just pretty much taken up most you time
that overwatch is still and also for
stocking oh what'd you say hold a hotel
go back what did you say you were quite
overwatch oh he knows better
oh not that the game's not good not that
he gave the game is fantastic the
problem I had I just had an issue with
winning game with ear cuz I just felt it
was you know multi player only confirmed
but that's for another day we'll discuss
it's not about me and my feelings about
overwatch but I know why people love it
great characters great balance great
cooperative play I get it
can I make one statement on that though
cuz I I get the whole no multibus
multiplayer-only
is that same thing with titanfall right
like I love titanfall but I missed a
single player and then time fall to team
I'll show that they could do a great
single player correct right here's what
Blizzard did though that I think people
overlook go watch their shorts that they
did the animation watch the seven or
eight of those that they produce and
then go play the game and it's a weird
dynamic but those are so expertly
produced and so deep that it gives you
an entire single-player story without
you ever picking up the controller I
with you know bill I just wish a lot of
that stuff was incorporated into the
area inside you know it's almost like
the argument for the people who hate
destiny vanilla because it was like yeah
you have this great story but it's in
the grimoire execs that's my only thing
because the characters are great I mean
it's took the animation everything about
the game and I'm really not trying to
hate on it you know I mean it's really a
good game that's the only people can
order me for saying this statement but I
get that you know people don't want
multiplayer only games winning Game of
the Year but at the other day I feel
like game of yours more about what game
is what game is best of the entire year
because that's why you have best shooter
the year best story pageant best
narrative I feel like it's more about
what that game does in the industry that
year more than it definitely changes
there's no doubt about I cannot
overwatch was out for a year they had
its own call absolutely absolutely so
that's gonna be some interesting
conversation or unplugged yeah oh yeah
we gonna get it above G - thanks O Lord
addict would have even played this week
uh destiny - a little bit of Destiny
tune you know I tried a little bit just
a dab or destiny you gotta get redo that
Ray no damn it no I did play something
else would know I played SP Louis off
what have you been playing this week
yeah actually cracked out on destiny -
no I mean it you know me that guy
I was i finished the story finally it
was alright I did um the crucible
challenges I played a lot of crucible
yesterday actually my job and I did a
nightfall yesterday so gaudy games oh I
know shout-out to Lord sinister and Loic
I bought two they got me through a knife
knife long just kind of insane I like to
do the prestige you'll pull your hair
out yeah yeah and when we finished it
when we finished it and lo sisters like
yeah this isn't even the hard one like
you know as Lord you know I was an
addict to the first one but for some
reason like you know I didn't think I
would hit destiny to like I hit destiny
one but I feel like it's worse ladies my
sleeping schedule is so messed up and
you can explore club you know I try to
go to sleep at a reasonable time last
night before work I try to be a
responsible adult but I was sat down I
was like I wonder if they're done with
the rain is a full-time job in itself
let's just say that steamworld dig 200
on the switch just came out on the
switch this past week fantastic
Metroidvania is that kind of 2d
platformer action adventure type stuff
excellent game excellent there pick it
up Lord King is it just been destiny for
you as well what ever been planned no no
no I must say I've been dabbling in on
my PC steam stuff checking out pop G
also playing my 3ds and getting that
Metroid and thank you nintendo it is
fantastic and destiny everything else
has been sparetime destiny helping out
are monkeys are hot monkeys loving
running through with our attic getting
the raid completed and shout out to
requinto it's in the chat it's going on
brother um
man listen destiny and getting everybody
through the whole team has to get
through now and everybody learn the
mechanics and learn emplacements
this priority for the rest of the month
so no that's me pretty much the same I
mean Destiny's pretty much taking up a
lot of my time I'm trying to get that
rate completed shout out to all the
clans everyone hooking us up shout the
Lord when you in the chat his gaming
things the same as mine right now it's
been at home it's been all testing to
whenever I'm work I'm on the road it's
been NBA 2k 18 on the switch man I
cannot get enough for that game it is a
full translation I'm having so much fun
my player my Park whatever it is the
career mode it is so well done you know
and um I'll be loving it I've been
loving the only thing they have to fix I
think 2k has a worldwide bug going on
right now that sometimes when you
started up it acts like it forgot your
character but then once you load into
the server it then you know redownload
everything you did because it's kind of
scared you think lost like your progress
photo other than that I mean it's been
real fun so that's pretty much been it
for me so you're gonna get this girl
show role and as far as the UM we had a
poll obviously last week the perk
results are in and people have spoken so
the Lord addicts question with TGS and
the resurgence of JRPGs in 2017 do you
think Microsoft should be more
aggressive in acquiring Japanese
influence gank the winner at 73% is the
yes Phil make it happen group what goes
so it was a landslide
oh and coming in that second was a my
23% was D Japanese caves or a dying /
niche genre group they lost thanks
participated in last week's poll the ILP
Twitter was intense for their love of
the Japanese game so real quickly what
it Lords think about this result kind of
in a landslide what do you feel about
this little girl as far as a Japanese
games so okay we got the law we got a
new poll caught up at the end of Twitter
at the end so stay tuned so we got some
great topics at the round
this week so I'm gonna set it on phenom
not going on with Xbox only begotten Son
our Lord and Savior feels fence emotion
going on so I wanted to talk about that
it looks like it was the executive you
know vice president of gaming you know
it was a huge huge promotion and um from
my standpoint was just cool to see you
know gaming being brought to the
forefront so I wanted to bring this
topic to the round table to all the
Lord's and what do we feel about uh Phil
getting this promotion as well as um you
know what it might mean in the future so
I know bill might have to be careful
about what he says but I'm let's start
with love there is this promotion by
Phil Spencer uh you know as someone who
works in the orc I think Phil's been a
spectacular leader for us yes love the
flexibility the freedom he gives his
teams and I thought it was a good move
for him and I'm I'm glad to see I mean
look I think that sometimes people read
too much into organizational structures
gaming's been part of Microsoft since
the beginning and will continue to be a
core tenant such as talked about it when
he talks publicly about the things that
Microsoft's committed to and this is
just a lot of confidence in the team and
Phil that we can go and continue to
execute against stuff no tell anyone the
Lord's want to jump in on the Phil
Spencer promotion it was an intense ball
- yeah you know what it's like you pick
something and it pans out for you a
winner that his strategy is working up
and you know what I guess is my biasness
because you know captain of the ship and
I said man this guy I like the way he
operator like that I was watching his
moves I said um I know I see great
things with this guy I did not like the
Scott I don't want anybody else to chime
in we're not a fan Sudan came off way
too smug I didn't like his vibe his vibe
was nasty
but my god Bill's vibe is so fantastic
and I know it's like probably a man
crush I have no idea you know Phil
probably a man crush on Phil but Phil
has been doing fantastic things you
understand like when I'm telling you
he's been changing the narrative going
forward if you don't look at his moves
it's been sold shitty Jaques that if it
was a problem here he dealt with it in
this way and he took away that narrative
it was a problem here he dealt with it
this way and she teaching we took this
out and replace it with this and he
enhanced everything as he's going for it
somebody up looked up saw that and saw
the moves that he was making it and he
did it without causing a big ruckus
without cause when I was you know
proclaiming anything he was just like
watch me smoke baby and he's been
smoking and now that he's in complete
control
I'm telling you we will be back as
number one completely across the board
this is this box when it hits and when
it comes up to my next segment when it
hits I'm going to tell you why he wins
and how he wins looking forward to it
Lord Lord sovereign what do we feel
about the Phil Spence promotion I think
it's a fantastic move I think it does a
lot to sort of a sure the gaming masters
as a whole that that microsoft has
invested it in xbox because you know
like again the the the loudness and the
fatalist mentality of a lot of the
internet like you see a lot of people oh
you know Microsoft gonna dump Xbox it's
not making money for them or not this
this is a vote of confidence in the fact
that and the fourth you know the fact
that fellow is going to report directly
to Sasha it means that who
is an integral part to everything that
Microsoft is doing and I think it means
it means great things for the Xbox
platform hopefully hopefully more money
in terms of you know games games that
they can acquire and and deals that
could be made to bring more games to the
platform yeah and I just think it's
great all around it's gonna be in a
funny way it's getting closer to that
ideal that was initially announced in
2013 where it has had things that were
they were perceived as negative but at
the same time it was trying to bring
this entire digital sort of universe
together
that I make is becoming more accepted in
four years yeah that is kind of
interesting yeah it was it was an idea
that that was sort of presented in a way
that came off a negatively I mean but I
know for us like us in this podcast we
were ready to go that route I said okay
well this is what Microsoft's system is
gonna be this is what PlayStation system
is gonna be but I'm all in on both you
know whatever it is is whatever it is
that obviously the masses had something
different to say about that um but I
just think I just think you're releasing
digital only error like that got kind of
bit or I just want to yeah forcing the
digital forcing the digital era that the
sort of negativity around not allowing
the use games and sort of the closed
that the closed the Waldorf garden thing
involved in that it just because a lot
of people felt that this was a gonna be
a natural progression anyway so there
was no need to create a system around it
and that's where the negativity came
from and you know and a lot to be honest
it could be summed up you know we have a
system for you and it's the Xbox 360
that's it's just people felt it was a
slap in the face
mmm-hmm yeah so I mean this is a
fantastic move for Xbox from for
Microsoft and gaming at large that think
we're gonna see some great things down
the line I feel or attic what do you
feel about the Phil Spencer promotion I
think it's you know it's definitely good
on Phil Spencer I mean I'm pretty sure
out of everyone he's definitely not the
one complaint
I mean at the end of the day I don't
really know what exactly it means I
don't know anything about that kind of
corporate stuff I don't know obviously
one would expect it would be good for
the gaming division of the you know
Microsoft company as a whole but you
know how much that's to be decided you
know we don't know what they have in
place we don't even know if this could
even impact this is just like you know a
title buff that you know uh you know
we've seen in a lot of other scenarios
and different industries sometimes
people were doing these jobs already and
there definitely gave the tossing it
point let's see you play so you're more
of the wait-and-see you know let's see
what happens kind of deal it's like I
don't know what Microsoft I don't know
they're their corporate ladder I don't
know how any of that goes you can't
really give inputs on you know policies
and stuff I don't know fair enough fair
enough fair enough I hear you coming
from yeah just what common real quick I
just want fable back that's all that's
all you want okay up the bill to get
that to film fable man what's fable this
is this I mean I'm kind of the same
lines with more sovereign on this I mean
you know I think this is actually pretty
good you know again I do hear what Lord
Atticus saying you know you know product
sometimes you know these things already
going on behind scenes and you know
maybe in place but I always felt since
you know Sasha came in you know 2014 and
assumed control of the Xbox division and
then Spencer I just like to see I love
to see Phil's growth and you know he
started as an intern being with
Microsoft is 88 and just to see the
progression to take over Xbox and you
know one thing I like about you guys
bill is that you know you guys are
gamers and and that's one thing that
always suited from Phil every
conversation I've had with him you know
any time we met in person and things
that nature so it's always good to see
the true gamers in these positions as
opposed to what I consider quote-unquote
suits you know respect
I don't know Terry Myerson personally I
don't want to disrespect anything you
know the guys up there in the platform
but you know I know Phil you know
personally and that's something that's
always you know came off from him
so it's good to see my gorgeous you know
what Microsoft do what Microsoft don't
do this company made one of my all-time
you know dreams I've ever wanted was to
go to e3 and they did it twice so I
can't really go too much in or anything
exactly and and in Microsoft does not
get enough credit for how they interact
with their community I mean you cannot
say that again about any other brand you
know it's really great what you guys do
so you know to me this is really cool I
think this is you know Microsoft Xbox
gaming at the big-boy table so to speak
you know and hopefully has a little bit
more influence hopefully you know the
cries of you know first party studios
and things of that nature and all these
things that you know Phil I know here's
all the time gets accomplished and I'm
excited so this is this was really cool
news to get and you know let's see what
happens in the future and so that's all
that got on it if the lords are good we
move on to the to the next habit so Lord
had it bring it to you you've got a I'm
gonna merge two things because I was
gonna talk about the cross play you know
but I think that's been destroyed as if
right now so what I want to talk about
is the pub GE horses fortnight issue
that anyone else is talking okay so I've
get in on it tied in with cross play in
and the pub gene first yeah so
apparently you know the whole pub G with
fortnight thing it's it's it's been big
you know I didn't think it was uh you
know I saw this I don't really see too
much into it but then you know it starts
blowing up everywhere I see YouTube
videos podcasts talking about it I think
I even saw it on Gainesville and it just
I want to ask what you guys think you
know the allegations of you know
fortnight's stealing from pub G this and
that like do you think there is a I
personally you know it was bound to
happen I don't think it's really a big
issue but then again I'm not in that
kind of industry I'm pretty sure I'd be
a little salty too but you know and then
after that you know just give your do
you guys think cross play would be
beneficial if it was yeah I would say
mandate but it was highly encouraged ok
let's start let's start with cross play
first and then we'll go
to pubsey versus 49 so let me see let me
jump in I'll jump in with with Brooklyn
cross play to me is something that I
really value only from the standpoint of
this this game sometimes that I love
that I feel that you know people move
away from you know maybe the online
community kind of dies out and to me
it's a strength to have more platforms
and more people playing on those servers
and opening up so that you know give me
nothing worse than as a game you love
and then you jump on and like the online
community is like you know only 50 or a
thousand people playing said give that
to me sucks so cross play is something
that is very attractive now I will say
this in Sony's defense is that you know
forget my history right Louis on because
I got a game was it in the Xbox 360 era
there was a Final Fantasy game that I
believe they wanted cross play or Sony
one it cross play and at the time
microphone Microsoft for whatever reason
said no wasn't that the case I don't
recall I don't know if it was the final
fantasy MMO when the first initials mm
oh okay it was the MMO I remember so I
don't I don't specifically recall but
yeah I mean again it goes back to the
issue of you don't need to play ball
when you're winning exactly so so again
I know it sucks from the gamer
perspective because I get it like I want
cross play I'd love to play with you
know my Sony guys in any type of
competitive environment or what-have-you
and be on the same service like that is
cool so that this bug that was
discovered by fortnight which was
accidentally unlocked you know it was
cool to see these guys going that and I
think even Phil made a comment he said
that the fight like them should keep
that they keep the bug off lay with each
other and I think that's awesome but at
the same time I'm not justifying what
Sony's doing I'm just saying I
understand has the market leader not
necessarily won't play ball with
Microsoft and give give these guys any
type of what they may feel as a
perceived advantage or so that that's
where I'm at what as far as cross play I
would love it to happen I would love
Sony to open up but I understand why
they might
but what are the rest of lords think
about this I think it's something that
would be very beneficial but you know
and when it comes down to it you know
look Cobalt you said cross plate between
destiny would be awesome oh I agree I
mean you know I want to take it a little
bit further if they would make cross
play on destiny too and you know
permanently I want Osiris and I want
love I haven't played it what's the new
one called Jonathan I played it one time
I want trials behind to be on Xbox or
Playstation and the other one to be on
the other one and once a month like they
are in banner they're facing each other
oh my god no
but Lord Lord bill any any dreams of a
cross play in the future I know I'm
putting you on the spot political speak
it's okay I think that there's two
elements to it it's what what gamers
would like to see and what what are the
realities of the business yes
you know we did just release better
together update the Minecraft which is
already sort of a phenomenon of multiple
man honestly thought that was probably
the biggest announcement that was at e3
is the fact that two platforms are
working together on one game yeah and if
you say if you take you're going say if
you take the the consoles themselves out
of the conversation right like my son
plays minecraft yeah actually this first
eSports tournament last year and his
friends all play it but one of them's
only got iPad one of them's got it on PC
obviously my son has it on everything
and and it's a challenge for them and
they don't have necessarily the brand
identity around it the place they play
it they have a bread then to be around
the game and so you know businesses have
to do what's best for their bottom line
yes and it makes the conversation more
complex
yeah totally when you come from Lord
Lord King what do you feel about this
whole cross play thing
listen if you don't want to believe it
watch what he's doing it he just got a
peep through the hourglass I mean he's
been a proponent for the PC he
understands the PC model remember it's
all the ecosystem and Microsoft okay so
if he's telling you to play on PC yes
please play through the Windows 10 store
[Laughter]
to merge these worlds and it will blow
stir the the Windows Store to the point
that if you're playing through window
play anywhere he's bringing that closer
together he's bridging that gap so yeah
um is it a great thing
yeah right so he's not gonna get down
they service up so they're not gonna get
down all right too much problems over
there on that side of the fence I'm when
they can when they can fix those servers
over there listen I have no problem with
this system I have no problem with their
games I think their games are great you
have a problem with the infrastructure
as far as they are internet servers and
everything else yes I do
you know how many messages I get a mom
telling me that we've been hacked I need
to change my password I will delete my
account with you guys I play regularly
on xbox or do I change your password
sometimes when I log in they ask me like
oh my xbox but it hasn't happened in a
long time there's no way I trust any
information over there
so for Microsoft yeah I really do
so but the PC gaming with Microsoft yes
that is very viable that is the way to
go that is fantastic you can get that
large set community and they're very
passionate over with their passion Xbox
community and we can go at it and like
um what attic says have iron banner PC
against gamers I mean come on that's
fantastic that's a good concept I love
it
you got just buddy with PC that we have
to be careful because of them obviously
with FPS is you know the mouse keyboard
[Music]
okay so we won't touch it we'll leave
that for your topic
that's if anyone's got anything done on
the first part of the fortnight thing
which is the cross play that most often
I mean I think me not being necessarily
the biggest multiplayer game but I just
think it's a positive thing I think at
all at some point get it together in
that regard and I just think it's a
positive for gamers in general you can
like I was saying before we're like you
know kind of the toxicity sometimes
around the internet and fanboy ISM and
stuff like that if you make it the norm
where these ecosystems are constantly
interacting I just think it kind of
diminishes that somewhat are you we're
gonna have more competition obviously
but it's gonna be more sporting it won't
be necessarily people being negative
towards each other because they're
constantly playing with each other
constantly in the same kind of sharing
spaces together the last one and I think
it would also bode well for the industry
at large because I think it would sort
of it would deter companies from making
these marketing deals as much because
you now you have to worry about the game
being able to be played with across you
know multiple platforms
so the marketing deals would it would be
difficult to sort of give one platform
you know a year's worth of stuff before
another platform it would be it would be
perceived as even more anti consumers I
think not sure it would serve to really
help gaming as a whole as a god you know
fair enough
I'm just gonna speed through the second
part of this whole fortnight cuz
obviously fortnight has been in the news
this week um with the whole pub G fiasco
with um you know the whole battle royale
mode we know pub G that's their claim to
fame you know just a real
just to paint the picture you know
obviously they used it the Unreal Engine
which epic has helped out with and um
now I believe for tonight is coming out
with a battle royale mode which the devs
of um you know because it is blow
happening exactly that said you know
they feel a little bit of a way about
them coming out with a quote-unquote
poverty mode and actually referencing
pub G in that description so yeah real
quick um you know this is a sometimes
this is a copycat league as far as video
game stuff like that do we feel that pub
G um has any like the stand I don't
think it was done with malice I think
they wanted you know they're all I mean
can can you really I don't know that
that you know that that aspect like that
but can you really like say something is
yours when it comes to a certain game
feature like battle royale game yeah
it's a gray one it's a gray area I know
what you mean and that's why I don't
know morally or legally you know what
leg they have to stand on but I do know
that they were in close relation with FA
because they worked on them with the
engine right so that's this gray area
where do they have the right to kind of
attack them for the staining that then
also I would say like I said with with
with epic and fortnight actually saying
pub GM promoting with their battle
royale mode so I kind of see both sides
kind of said you know me it's a tough
one but lost off looking what do you
guys feel
let's all go first yes up yeah I think
that that's the issue there the fact
that they you know they license unreal
tech to make their game and then you
know the the the unreal guys go and they
make a mold in their game that's still
similar honestly i if you look at the
mechanics of both games they're very
different in that you know you plan a
battle royale mode in fortnight if
somebody's attacking or something like
that you can like build a wall in front
of you like it's totally it changes the
mechanics of what this type of battle
Oriole game is so it's it's kind of
different but then again the
similarities and why and things like
that the whole concept of like the
murder Island thing is sort of the same
so I can understand where they're coming
from
in that regard because again it just it
just seems like it's it's not
necessarily the best thing to do when
you're you're gay
royalties from this company on their
game so it's like yeah it's it's it's a
funky area to be in that's for sure it I
have you know I don't know what sort of
legal merit that you know like to stand
on they have in this regard but I get it
in terms of the copycats you're gonna
see a lot of them it's so that's know if
they're if they're issue is that at
large you can forget about it because
shout out the lady dallona in a chance
she said she thinks pub she only had it
fueled by seeing something Lord King
what do you feeling yeah called G versus
okay I think it's kind of messed up if
you help them build something they're
using the engine and then you turn
around and you have the feature that
they have we all know the problems that
fortnight is having is it up to the
standards of pop G's playing on own no
it's not it's not pushing the numbers
that they're pushing so of course when
you're down and you're seeing something
that's successful you're gonna reach
over and try to emulate that any way
possible now this is the problem you had
the inside track okay so you saw them
build it you saw her win he was like you
probably had a little twist on it by
quote sovereign said we're able to do
this in our game okay so you know
imitation is just the most serious form
of flattery and okay hey I mean maybe
they're soo yeah I don't know um but
just like she said in the chat um by
them talking about it and highlighting
it they put more emphasis on it and
maybe some people that weren't looking
at for it and I said well working at a
pub she experienced over there and they
went that way um so personally I don't
have a problem with it um as far as that
goes because again if it's well and it's
done well on another platform and you're
trying to get a leg up you trying to get
sales and stuff like that they're gonna
exhaust every avenue to make your game
successful because they
closing Delft houses like at a rapid
pace so if you're trying to stay
relevant and viable in this uh
cantankerous environment you're gonna do
whatever you got to do
yeah I mean I I recall a situation where
you know remember when the whole leaders
at 4v1 craze started would evolve and
I've seen a lot of games you know doing
that copycat kind of thing just real
quick I want to give the law bill and I
want to get him in trouble but uh I just
was gonna ask for a bill as far as like
have you seen situations maybe similar
in the past and I was gonna ask you if
um in reference to those kind of
competitions or similarities and if any
legal things can be taken or and if
you've ever seen anything similar in the
past coming up in the industry well I
mean even outside the industry anybody
can sue anybody right just brag for
gusts here's like here's what I'll say
pop G's a big partner we've worked with
them for a long time as a company and so
as a company man I have a perspective
there I actually have a really good
friend who worked with me at Xbox Store
and is now I produced her on fortnight
and we were in humouring together
abstain because there's no way I can say
anything about I feel you know fair
enough inside that's all that's all I
won D that's cool so we got we fell on
this whole situation probably hopefully
these guys can work it out and you know
both games can be successful there's a
lot riding especially with pub Jean we
we definitely excited for pub G on the
Microsoft side you know as an exclusive
and what time is or whatever it may be
but the game seems huge on the PC market
and we're excited we're gonna move on
and Lord King we want to talk about
lights camera action has been fired in
your direction and I believe they are
lethal brother microsoft has debuted a
feature for those people that are
fortunate enough
be in the Alpha members circle the
feature is you're using plug-and-play
cameras for Microsoft apps which is
Skype and mixer now I know you probably
say that's that's nothing well the fact
that you have to buy a piece for the
Xbox one X to put your connect in that's
a barrier some people don't want to make
the phone call some people have connect
sitting in the corner and they don't
really care about getting an extra piece
to hook up to a system that they have
you know a lot of people don't want to
do extra steps to get one thing done but
a plug-and-play so the fact that they're
doing this and they see the communities
that do twitch and live streaming and
they're pushing mix they're very hard to
to be used across the world
competitively um and the plug and play
feature this is the Deaf nil for the
Kinect
and I want to know how you guys feel
about it and back to Lord monkeybars
Proclamation that mouse and keyboard is
coming this X is ushering in the blurred
lines between PC and console ever so
slightly in Phil's grand vision I want
to know how you guys feel about this new
tech that their debut for the Alpha
member circle let's get it to Lord Bell
from a standpoint of all the testing of
like the USB cameras and things like
that for Microsoft's like mixer and
Skype what he can possibly talk about
give us some insight on if possible well
I mean I don't I'm part of the platform
team it sews but some cases we just we
all work on our own features and we all
work on our feature so what I would say
is mixers been a great addition to the
console and having having them come into
the fold from the standpoint of all of a
sudden anybody could stream anything and
they could just jump right in and you
know prior to that PC was really the
dominant platform still is but it but
the but the Iberian entries
because you have to have a PC you have
to have stuff setups that you can
broadcast and all of a sudden anybody
with an Xbox and a Kinect was able to
jump into this that doesn't mean it's
always good quality but anybody can get
involved and I do think that I was
thrilled to see the announcement about
the other USB cameras being supported
because now you just increased people's
ability to engage and I and I think that
look the Kinect is an expensive piece of
hardware it's got a lot of high-tech
capabilities over and above what you
would use it for as a webcam and so
having some functionality become
available to other customers who haven't
jumped into the Kinect side is great at
the same time the connect continues to
be a great console component because you
can do nothing if you have it set up and
immediately become a broadcaster who can
feed yourself as well there are times
where I see my kids get online and start
streaming their gameplay and I have to
text my wife at the house then she yells
at them and then also the camera goes
dead I mean it really is opening it up
so that anybody can become a game
streamer it's an amazing start big
speakers feel a little bit I got a I
love the NHL 18 stream full hockey gear
Lord Vil went out there plates of nature
I saw you I saw you had to give you a
shout out that was hard cool yeah thank
you I did it twice I did it my goalie
gear for the three on three
we had the e producers come on and they
demoed the this feature for three on
three for the first time and I actually
played in my goalie gear so I was
playing my catcher in my blocker that
was impossible plus it's just hot in a
studio because got all the gear on I got
the lights no so when I came back to do
the announce I did it just my regular
hockey gear I just played and you know
what because we got a big controller I
could actually play with my gloves on
how did you play that was good to say I
saw you was he even able to have the
dexterity to play with the controller
well mixer stuff would you ever consider
getting in the stream and I know I know
Mikey borrow my car he's big on that
would you ever consider
all right so I I love doing it the
challenge is to full one I'd only would
watch me because I'm awful it why most
of the games that I love doing it and in
fact we I've got something special for
next week okay okay though you got it
out if that's the case you got to give
up there mix a handle so the guys we get
everyone to follow you yes don't pay
attention man because I thought we'd as
we get closer to the time what are the
Lord's got on the rest it is the camera
stuff as far as what's going on it's a
lord addict what do you feel about this
cool options but that's better so you
got that right
yeah I agree with with both Lord Lord
bill and Lord Lord King in the fact that
yeah the line is being blurred more and
it's giving more accessibility to more
people we got to remember that the vast
majority of Xbox owners now don't have a
Kinect thanks Colin
so the fact that anybody can just you
know going to a Best Buy and buy any
third-party USB a camera and be off and
running if they want to start streaming
that's fantastic and and again that that
part of gaming has expanded so much over
the last few years that you know look at
us here just doing a podcast where a
couple years ago that wasn't something
that considering so it's just like it it
again it goes back to what I said before
about how that original vision for the
Xbox one as being that one box it keeps
moving closer to that vision and just
the fact that you're allowing
third-party anything onto the system
this makes it more more cost-effective
for the consumer to you know be go out
and purchase and spend what they want to
spend on a piece of hardware as opposed
to the Kinect which is yes it is an
advanced piece of hardware but it works
specifically in that ecosystem and
nowhere else so yeah this is fancy point
good point myself y'all jump in on that
yeah I think that I'm with you 1,000%
low soft I think is great I think it you
know provides options and I mean look I
I still have my Kinect great piece of
tech you know 1080p cam the motion
sensor and all that stuff but like you
said the key point is it was locked into
just yeah
box and also the key point was that you
know a lot of people who've now
subsequently picked up a mark sitting on
an Xbox have picked it up during the S
era right and that's the way Kinect was
not a mandatory part of the bundle so to
have that option is really cool coming
into the debut of the Xbox one X you
know getting to see you know these
services being used Skype and and mixers
is huge right now
you know seeing that thing blow up and
giving everybody that ability you know
to be able to do it I think it's really
really cool and to see you know what I
like I want to commend Microsoft's to
see them be flexible because a lot of
times you see companies when it's a you
know proprietary product they just want
to push said product don't want to give
you the option of a quote unquote
competitor so to speak you know I mean
when another camera and things of that
nature so I think that's really cool to
see so I'm excited about it and I
thought it was a good topic looking else
to finish off lights camera action
no this is just the fact that I think
there's a fantastic idea
instead of differ a lot of these
thoughts was pushed to the table in the
beginning I know they invested a lot in
the Kinect and I know they wanted it to
be successful because it showed that
it's you know sold what 13 million units
before and um they felt that if we can
get these units in the box they could
see the value and I see that mind asset
but also it's sold 13 million units on
its own so if you would you know had it
as a separate peripheral and you know
you can upgrade as you go along and the
price of the Xbox would have been at the
same price of the PlayStation or lower
um then you wouldn't have been in the
big hole that you were in and it didn't
feel like everything was being forced it
made it seem like everything was being
forced but it actually wasn't but now
like I said it out of the box and he
gave you options you know he gave you
the option that you could use your whole
connect or now you can use you can go to
snoop I can man so
all these things as being possible under
the new philosophies and the new
philosophies is panning out is he's
working and making things happen
nice the division is there we were all
excited well like I said flexibility
options always a good thing so we're
gonna move on to the final topic Lord
starve this is you talk about TGS what's
been going on yeah so uh TGS actually I
think today is the final day of TTS
proper but Sony had a press conference
early on before the actual show started
and Nintendo had some announcements and
whatnots I just wanted a it's been kind
of low-key I am TGS hasn't been as big
in recent years as it was a long time
ago but I think considering this year
how many great Japanese games we got I
was hoping to see some really big
announcements coming out of Japan and
they kind of kind of kind of
conservative it like nothing too crazy
but again I know somebody's gonna have
something bigger towards the end of the
year they still have Paris games week
and they still have a PSX and I'm sure
we'll get some sort of Nintendo Nintendo
switch direct that before the end of the
year again so we'll get more infor in
that regard so let me start off with
Nintendo like I said we just they had
direct a few weeks ago so the bulk of
the information that they wanted to sort
of get out to the public was in that
direct so what we got from TGS is they
they show two more Fire Emblem Warriors
gameplay mm-hmm the game again if you're
if you're a dynasty Warriors guy that
moves you so type of game it's the game
by all accounts is beautiful kind of
frantic it's definitely showpiece for
what what the switch could do it's
running beautifully again if that's your
type of game I guess we're getting that
at the beginning of next year okay um
same attack on Titan 2 is coming to the
switch from koa Tecmo and that looks
pretty if you're a big fan of the manga
and the anime well that's coming next
yeah so much really trailer fire it's
fantastic that game play that game play
from what I've heard like the game play
is really cool and you know the
grappling stuff that you do when you're
swinging
from you know from Titan the Titan is
supposed to be pretty cool so if you're
into that I heard the game is pretty
decent
um Dragon Quest builders is finally got
shown for the switch and this is a game
this is a Minecraft like game in the
Dragon Quest universe
they kind of did gangbusters when they
came out on that believe was on Vita and
PS don't poke me on that in PlayStation
4 um but it's again it has those
minecraft sensibilities in the Dragon
Quest universe so I think it's gonna do
very well on the switch when it finally
comes over mm-hmm another thing that
came out of Japan was the fact that
Metroid sold well you know considering
how Metroid usually sells in Japan it
actually definitely sold to do something
like 70% of their stock they so about
32,000 copies I think they had about 43
that they made for the initial launch
window so the fact that Metroid is doing
well in Japan bodes well all around the
world hopefully again we're gonna we're
getting prime at some point hopefully
we'll get on this remake onto the switch
also I can't say that I disagree with
that like it's probably that gonna
happen anytime soon if it ever does I
won't I won't disagree with that
they showed Resident Evil Revelations 1
& 2 which both look pretty good at
running very well it seems like they
were based off of either the Xbox 360 or
ps3 ports or the ports that came to Xbox
one just recently came Xbox one and ps4
and just downgraded the game to look
like they ran beautifully so that that
that's pretty good um what else do we
have
Square Enix show lost fear mmm that RPG
from the guys who made uh i'm setsuna
anti-sexual yeah RPG based off so that
looks and then yeah there was some there
was some doom ready that's the love and
talked to me so yeah we talked about
this last week about what I hope for the
game and what did the reality of the
game is this
so wait hold on this one on this I would
call this a ven Denis stalemate
Lavelle's there was no bet really but my
hope that was that it was 60 frames per
second the game is gonna run at 30
frames per second what you think that I
made is that I equated I equated frame
rate with speed of the game the game is
so fast right the game is still fast but
smoothness is is a different story the
game runs smoothly but it's running at
30 frames per second just the overall
speed of the game is still fast so the
game is gonna run 720p in handheld and
dock mode so there's no mum there's no
love right okay okay
no uprising is not long it's what you
have to do it now if you look at that
game I played to that entire game I've
watched nearly a half hour footage of
that game that's doing like the only
concessions that have been made
obviously is in the detail of the
graphics which still looks fantastic but
the game plays I do okay and again I
don't they I don't think this will be
anybody's primary version or should be
any primary way of playing doom
hopefully you have it our ps4 or Xbox
one or a piece you can play it there but
it's cool that Nintendo has the option
in it that in there Bethesda showing
that support for the team by all
accounts it is a fantastic port main I
expect I expect the same from
Loic king wants to snicker and jump in
continue you know what's a snicker point
I just couldn't help but I have to start
meeting my mic to apologize sir and I'll
bend the knee on the fact that I really
didn't think that it would look like
that to be honest Richard it looks
pretty decent
I saw what digital foundry did on the
game
I know exactly what it was running at so
I kind of had an inside track I'm
laughing at it ahead of time um but like
you said there's nobody's primary but
for somebody it is their primary so you
know for that somebody's that's out
there that only has a switch that only
could get a switch because they Wi-Fi or
whatever in the area doesn't work good
or whatever and this system is skated
and telling me to you I say kudos that
they even got the game won in fact you
know so yeah it actually works so me
snickering is just me coming from nah
but as far as like the Tokyo Game Show
stuff there's any that stuff interest
you or actually from a Microsoft
standpoint have you ever got a chance to
actually go to one of those events I'm
just curious
no I've never been took a game show I've
been to I've been the III I've been to
trying to joy obviously throw the nice
console launch which is just a
staggering event the mass of humanity
they're all dressed up in costumes
air-conditioned aircraft carrier
aircraft but it's you know I watch the
show just as it's not as an employee but
as a fan is a series that I really liked
I liked all I the Atlas is one of my
favorite for so uh lots of smiling it
right now he's a human persona thing
those are great series and so I just I
watch it as a family kind of interesting
nice fair fair though did you get a
chance I'm sorry let's all finish it now
I'll give it to Lana oh yeah just
quickly and so it's only kind of had an
interesting showing um because you will
you know they're gonna have something
Paris games week and you know that's
gonna be PSX at the end of the year so
with a Sony basically one second I had
my notes in front I mean I lost it for a
moment but um the coolest thing to come
out of Sony was this game called left
alive that basically has
kind of visa these metal gears sort of
people around metal gear people around
armored core people around Xenoblade who
worked on these type of games coming
together to make a game that you know
kind of has metal gear esque
sensibilities that are calling it a
third it kind of fits into that mold
that we've always talked about that
third-person over-the-shoulder yes
action-adventure slash game with you
know RPG sensibilities they just kind of
throw it in a blender and out comes a
game so this is some square enix um and
the cool thing about it is that you have
the you have showed you in question Kawa
who was the character designer behind
metal gear and what who seen any sort of
Metal Gear art or covers you know what
that is and you know that style so he's
he's handling the character uh creations
for this system for this game but then
you have people around it from Final
Fantasy Kingdom Hearts people worked on
Mobile Suit Gundam and like I said
general bache Chronicles so they showed
a little bit of gameplay in the trailer
and again it just looks like a
third-person sort of action game but the
cool part about it is that it just seems
like it's it almost seems and we'll talk
about this in a second it just seems
like people are sort of not afraid to go
back to the Kojima well um and and and
maybe something maybe making something
in that vein so it'd be interesting how
they this games supposed to come out
2018 we'll see how its received overseas
and we'll see if it's something that
that we're would be excited to get over
on this side so it's just interesting
just the people around it and to see
that I'm sort of trying to emulate that
that experience and go back to that no
bomb so apart from that like they showed
some Detroit stuff become human game
looks so good that's what I'm waiting
for they finally they finally gave a
release date of January for Monster
Hunter world and I don't know if it's a
worldwide release or just a Japanese
release but again that's a game that and
Lord King will agree like we we tried to
get into on Nintendo platforms and it
just didn't happen
with this game being as pretty as it is
like a and sort of streamlined in a way
they're sort of bringing new players I
can see it becoming I can see it
becoming thick if again again that that
gateway for new players is sort of easy
to to get into and not obtuse like the
the older games have been they've shown
more stuff of shadow of Colossus a
little bit more that Dragon's crown that
that 2d side-scroller they have like a
4k version coming out they call it
Dragon's crown Pro so that's pretty cool
and I honestly do Oh as owner of the
Ender's what kind yeah so the only I'm
just coming back that's what I talked
about with Kojima they they're they're
not sort of afraid to go back to it to
that well so zone of the enders coming
back remastered and they're also making
a full fledged V R version and that is
that's cool a because only Ender's does
a pretty fast game it's not a
slow-moving net game so it'd be
interesting how see how they incorporate
that into into VR to not make it pukey
so that that's gonna be interesting the
CD Tony platform or is that for the vibe
and oculus you know that is that is psvr
yes P so far it's psvr and that leads me
to my next point which is what they
showed using them on VR stuff they they
went more into depth with all the
supermassive games that were coming out
the Bravo Team the prequel to until dawn
so for anybody who's kind of been on the
fence repeat with psvr I think more and
more than showing that they're willing
to invest in big experiences more
smaller experiences different types of
experiences I know that by the end of
this year I'm sure we'll see more
package deals for the psvr I know right
now they've had they finally started
incorporating the camera in the package
which is something that's big for people
because the camera on its own is like 50
bucks so they're starting to make better
package deals and I assume that for the
holidays is gonna be even more so
anybody's been on the Friends of our
peers VR I think they're showing a
commitment
which is great from Sony when it comes
to you know things that are not their
primary console they're always been sort
of hit or miss with you know how they
support these things after they come out
yeah so I think I think they're invested
in psvr and it shows no no no no yeah
there's a lot a lot of stuff was
announced I'm glad you gave us to recap
because I definitely missed a lot of it
oh my destiny play and stuff ever get
into the way catch was going on but oh
no this was really cool when real quick
launch and I don't know if you got a
chance to see did you get a chance to
watch so low soft thanks for the recap
thank you everybody's been playing
destiny I had to pull myself away
that's a because otherwise like you're
like in a cave and you're not paying it
isn't going on
that's what definitely does what's up
exactly one other thing for us Sega
heads virtual on is coming back anybody
yeah virtual on and I think a I know
Lord
maybe Lord Bill can speak to this uh the
the oratorio tangram there were two
games that came to um to Xbox Live
Arcade on the 360 like remasters of
these be the original games that
Dreamcast games and the Saturn game um
these are like one on one mech fighting
games that we initially saw when we
talked about earlier about how the
arcade was the testing ground for all
this new tech when you went into an
arcade and you saw virtual arm for the
first time and you saw that cabinet you
lost your mind
you just lost your mind because it was
it was this huge imposing thing and the
gameplay was fantastic so it's coming
back but it's a little weird how it's
coming back they're associating it with
kind of an obscure box cure for us
Japanese a sort of manga so it's about
these students who have superpowers so
they're incorporating them corporated
virtual on it's essentially oratory
Tangra my fake with with this with this
manga and so it's students in like in
robot form battling one
I'm quite um again it's back it's back
and it's go and see that it's back nice
know billion I don't know if you guys
know we released the 360 BC version last
week but it's Japan oh really
those sort of fly under the radar we've
done it we don't know half dozen or so
Japan only releases or Xbox owners in in
Japan and virtual on was one we just we
just put back there were there were many
a nice loss to battling on the Dreamcast
and virtual also absolutely wrap this
thing up soon careful we got a nolo bill
has his bears to attend to during the
Clinton era but earthworm jim the
quarterback real quick we got um two
things we want to get into one we had
all the new poll then we want to shape
up so it's a new poll this week we're
gonna put this up on the I love podcast
Twitter very soon it's gonna be okay
with developers like square with final
fantasy 15 take to what NBA 2k and
Bethesda with doom slash Wolfenstein to
attempting to wreak to be creative and
pulling these Triple A titles over to
the switch does lower frame rate or
resolution discourage you from buying
these tiles so that's gonna be the
question and answers gonna be a yes you
don't want the Lord King [ __ ] experience
no we want more portable triple-a titles
that's gonna be the question it's gonna
go up on our page Twitter soon make sure
you guys Rock the Vote I want to give
our Lord addict a question the ad for
law bill for lag yet so questions little
bit before we close out I just had one
quick question Lord Bill since this is
an xbox podcast what's your favorite
Xbox game oh it's like you asked me what
my favorite child is room
there's a set of games obviously the
original halo will always have a special
place talk about it well this this is
when I was still doing the telecom work
week and I was in one of the buildings
we had there was also a partner lab so
we would come in and partner to build
out technology showcases and so we had a
we had a fake living room and one of the
first things we did was we put an Xbox
in it and then me and a couple my
buddies we everyday after work we would
go order pizza we sit down we play for
screen call for screen multiplayer on
that console and then eventually a
couple there and you gave everyone to
work right was that and you gave
everyone to work right you won every
game it was it was an intense and fair
competition but so we beat so then
eventually the office so there was
exchange was in the same building couple
those guys walked by they're like hey
can we play we're like sure so we set
him up in a lab where they had it on a
projector and then over time like every
night different product groups started
hearing about it and they come play us
and we were we were holding court we
were beating everybody because we played
all the time so one of my buddies who
worked at ms comm micro column said hey
I got some friends want to play what
great bring them over and we got
destroyed hasn't even one of those
things like we're riding high we've
beaten everybody for boots and turnout
today we're the testers from Bungie so
that game will always have a special
place because there remain many hours
burn with some of my best friends I also
only am and this is a corporate speak
like I love the board light series we
partners I feel bad with with with their
latest trials I think that the fans have
said that they want borderlands games
and human whatever they decide to do in
the future but there are so many and you
know it just depends on overwatch is
obviously one for me right now but I
mean there's always like ask me what's
your favorite movie or what's your
favorite song its kind of defend them
you had a question another question when
I got the six oh I was just gonna ask
you guys did you uh you know maybe not
uh Lord Bill might not know because he
he doesn't really follow the destiny
community but uh good
he tweeted on I can't I don't know if it
was someone from over there a gear but
he tweeted someone was like how many
retweets and tweet and likes is it gonna
take me to get to get um Borderlands on
the Nintendo switch and the dude was
like 1 million any comedies like
consider it done it would be great that
space I mean what les is such a fun
cooperative game so it's just like to
see it come back it'll be awesome you
know just me personally that's cool but
we want to thank you guys for really
taking the time I just get you know you
got you know really appreciate you it's
always a pleasure talking to you every
three and um hopefully we see it at the
next one again man so uh thanks a lot
for coming on the show I really
appreciate it it's so cool to get to
interact with people who use the stuff
that you that you build um you guys are
the reasons we do it
much appreciated man thanks a lot cool
so we're gonna also want to let the
people know on where they can find you
because I'm obviously you're gonna be
doing some mixer stuff going on soon so
I want you to promote all that good
stuff here on the IOP so you got you got
to mix a page up and everything where
can people find you so I the easiest way
to find me is at my twitter at WC
Stillwell and then I put everything we
do because sometimes I'm using them on
my account something doing with
corporate accounts because we're
promoting something so just if you
follow that I will put everything I do
on that nice nice and are we allowed to
talk about the gamertag or we keep
another axe so you thought about the
gamertag it's now in promotional
material so thanks can't avoid it it's
wall of build spaces between all right
Sam Winchester great wall bills absolute
pleasure so we're gonna close this thing
out soon on because you know outros
popping Lord addicts you got stuff going
on with the gaming addict show what's
going on with you if I'm finding I'm
trying to do stuff with gaming addict
but I'm telling you like this I even
told myself I'm going to put out videos
yeah I put out a video yesterday
ironically was destiny too related and I
was like I'm gonna put it on out
and I'm sitting here like before the
podcast I'm like but I can run some
crucible real quick do you want to
announce that I'm five five subscribers
away from a thousand so definitely
please sell me something aiming attic
please yeah let's get them to a thousand
guys so appreciate all that all that
support well I do want to thank Lord
Bill come for coming on again it's
definitely really appreciative I know
with a you know this statue that you
have you know sometimes doing stuff like
this can be a little iffy and I
appreciate you giving us that trust and
let and coming on here especially ly
live is a big thing yes but I definitely
want to take the time to thank him again
absolutely absolutely Lord saw we're
gonna find people find you yeah
absolutely Thank You Lord girl for
coming on man we would appreciate it
anytime we get to talk to people
associated with the you know the
platforms that we love it's fantastic so
thanks again for coming by um and the
fine people could find me on PSN and
xbox live at the Excel room and will you
be online though that's the question we
can find things oh I like to say thank
you for lord bill for coming through and
the fact that he was sharing his gaming
experience and I can go all the way back
which brother on all that stuff was all
that went straight over my head Michael
I like I knew the moment that went you
know I kind of gave it a little bit of a
of an evaluation like yeah this is not
ending anytime soon at that point in
time was you supposed to soak that
innocent man I missed out and he was
supposed to go seek that are you
supposed to get a backpack and go from
arcade
you really think I wanted any part of
that history Instagram Twitter most
importantly you can find me a
PlayStation Network at xbox360 lover old
one alright thank you so much that
gaming realness on the IO fee well he's
telling you not what you want to hear
but what you needed
thanks again Lord Bill for coming
through dropping all those gems great
stories you know you are welcome back on
the ILP anytime anytime there's a stop
through and talk game with us we really
appreciate you taking time out that busy
schedule and I just wanna do some real
quick things pay your bills make sure
you guys um hit that like subscribe to
the ILP on all the inner circle need
network media outlets including YouTube
iTunes Google Play and also that amazing
tech giant Exige in our patreon the
links in the description all that
support really helps the Lord it is much
appreciated
we've got more things cooking up for you
guys it's gonna be fun I know it's one
o'clock I see the chats like football
football I know the fantasy lineups
we're gonna get this big out of here but
um again thanks a lot bill for coming
through and we are gonna end this show
peace